and now
Brandon six
boy
sha we have a special special guest
today it is the man the myth the legend
he's the face of one Championship he's
the CEO it's Chri and he he's tuning in
now and you're in you're in Singapore
boss yeah yes I I just got back into
Singapore I've been literally flying
non-stop around the world yeah you're
you're a jet Setter man but you kind of
got to be with everything going at one
Championship I mean just to start you
know it's uh what are we about 15 days
now into 2024 2023 was a was a good year
for one Championship a lot of uh a lot
of activity um I saw firstand yeah for
sure I mean I mean we broke every uh
record high uh in terms of viewership
metrics in terms of revenues in terms of
number of countries number of events I
think we did uh 50 50 plus events last
year 55 events something like that last
year um and and so we broke yeah every
single metric we track we broke a record
high and obviously a big moment was our
our us debut as well um and uh yeah so
it just it was just a crazy year but
this year is already going to be even
bigger you know we're we're slated now
for a minimum of 61 events potentially
70 events this year 61 is a minimum it's
locked and loaded um and uh you know all
all across Asia
Middle East and the US and and
potentially Europe so uh big big stuff
uh in store cuz you have distribution
with uh Sky Sports now in UK too right
which is Big yeah that's that is massive
you know it's Europe's largest uh sports
broadcaster by far big boy has a 50%
yeah it has a 50% audience share uh it
is the big 800 pound gorilla in terms of
um Sports Broadcast in all of Europe and
and we're just lucky because they chose
us uh uh over the um you know other
players yep which is which is a good
sign I mean when you look back on last
year I mean this is going to be the
toughest one to beat the rat Tang vers
super leak the super fight that was back
in I think SE August September the most
the most watched Muay Thai event ready
ever ever yes in history 100 million
plus viewers around the world it was
insane yeah it was insane I don't know
if you saw that fight but that was an
insane
War crazy I mean if you watch it you got
to look at the micro you know slow-mo
seconds by second because the elbows the
knees the I mean you it was so fast you
couldn't catch it all you could just see
is blood dripping but it was because
just
the yeah strategic fight but it was an
allout war and yet you know the tools
they were using the time the faints the
combinations I mean truly truly like you
have to sit there and Rewind it to
really capture the Beauty and the Art of
what they were doing yeah they're
they're so fast then you also had I mean
that was a big moment then you had Angel
Lee's retirement which was that was a
tough one that was a tough one but
passed the torch to you know stamp Fair
Tex that was a big moment yeah yeah
definitely um you know it's it's uh we
just had uh three days ago with our you
know our uh first show on Amazon this
year um the Victoria Lee Award right
Victoria Lee is Le sister 18 years old
um you know passed away and and and and
uh you know Angela has now caught you
know has really uh as a result retired
from her her younger sister passing and
then now dedicating her life to mental
health awareness and suicide awareness
and just making sure that uh you know
the legacy of Victoria Lee uh lives on
through you know I mean Victoria was
genuinely one of the the most incredible
hearts of gold you you ever made like
just a nice wonderful authentic loving
kind giving person and and Angela wants
to continue that Legacy yeah the whole
family is just I mean everyone's so nice
that that was that was a tough one you
know there's some highlights last year
but that that was probably the the
darkest it got and know Ang is doing the
Lord's work now you know you see her all
over and spreading the message so you
know she's a fighter man whe whether
she's in that in that ring or not she's
still keeping up the good fight so yeah
I love Angela but moving forward to
20124 I mean good for me good for the
American fans you guys announced two big
boy moves September 6 you're back in my
hometown now you're in Colorado but
you're not the Broomfield Event Center
where when I uh attended the event last
year you guys decided to go even bigger
and you're at the ball Arena and that's
where the world champion Denver Nuggets
play that's jokic Court over there so
you guys decide decide to step your game
up and and bring it to the ball Arena
which is a big move well yeah well you
know our fan base cuz again we track uh
every metric around the world viewership
engagement numbers across TV social
digital Etc and our fan numbers are just
growing like it's insane in in the US
and uh obviously um we sold out several
weeks in advance when we did it at
Broomfield and um you know that was our
kind of like put your toe in the water
see where we're at and we just we had no
idea Brendan and you were there how
rabid our fan base is it was insane
insane I mean we sold out several weeks
ago several weeks before the event and
then the fans were just I mean
they knew rot tank they knew St I mean
it was crazy they were chanting their
name like you know um and so I I'm
pretty confident we're going to sell out
ball Arena as well I think ball Arena 15
15 or 20,000 capacity and then Atlanta
we're also you know in in I think the uh
where the State Farm yeah
think that's where the Atlanta Hawks
played right I think correct uh right so
I think that's that's also 15 20,000 I
think we're going to sell that one out
as well so I mean uh it's just uh you
know I think we yeah Tippy Toe with our
toe in the water and then from there on
from September onwards we're going to do
uh uh one event per quarter in the US a
minimum and eventually we'd like to get
to once a month in the US uh you know
per the Amazon plan I mean the Amazon
Prime video you know ideally having a
one you know on ground event in the US
once a month would really ignite things
for fans yeah I think what you know I
was in person at the Broomfield events
then I think what blw me aways selling
out I expected that I didn't realize how
big of a I guess you could say a
crossover star stamp is stamp and Mikey
mush Mesi like the crowd went it was
like a Taylor Swift concert when st came
out it was insane dude it was it was
like a GSP in Toronto it was nuts that's
that that's exactly it so that's what I
mean like I was shocked I mean I was I
had no idea what to expect I I I
honestly didn't know if we were GNA sell
that or not and that's why I was
conservative and going with a 7,000
Cedar venue um and and uh you know
everyone's say no no you know on my team
they're all saying CH our brand is big
enough to go to you know 15 20,000 seer
in America you got to do it for the
debut I said no no I I just don't have
conviction I have no idea where we where
we sit in America smart and uh the fact
yeah I agree with you I mean our Our
Stars whether it was Muay Tha or
grappling or MMA were treated like
Superstars they were treated like you
know like exactly like Taylor Swift
would by n yeah it was nuts it was nuts
yeah so and I assume I mean we're not
Ann you're not the the the fights on on
here I'm sure as it gets closer but I
assume because those are big American
cards you're going to bring out the the
big hitters for sure for sure for sure
yes all the big stars will be coming out
um and and you know we're gonna we
actually haven't uh sat down yet with
the matchmaking team and figure out what
what the cards are going to look like
but yeah I mean there's no way we're
going to come in with a small card yeah
and I assume because you know DJ he's
blowing up he you know he's doing his uh
YouTube show which is great you know
he's crushing up there I love to see it
and you know I absolutely love DJ you
know I'd like to see in Denver DJ versus
Bradley Martin just throwing things out
there he's 260 he's 260 Chri he's 260
though if we're gonna do it you know
they talked about doing it at Bradley's
gym at my studio I'm like why don't make
it an exhibition fight you know
somewhere be maybe before the event or
something like that just so fans can see
how this goes down you know that that's
a good idea Brandon I I I didn't thought
of it but um yeah I mean DJs kind of in
that zone where he's really really
cemented his status as the goat having
won World titles in in in uh both the
largest organizations you know UFC and
one in the world and then on top of it
um you know he's just I mean think about
it who in their right mind would do a
super fight mixed rules against R Tang I
mean he went toe-to-toe with one of the
greatest Strikers on the planet um one
of the greatest knockout artists so you
know DJ's done it all you know I think
the only thing left for me for him would
be like a a super fight mixed rues with
Mikey mumii that would be also very
interest OB Mikey being um arguably the
greatest PM for pom Grappler on the
planet today definitely an argument we
had the Ruto Brothers on firing the kid
and they talked about you know obviously
Jiu-Jitsu is their thing and again those
kids they come in the room the energy is
insane just their Vibes like we
everybody was in such a good mood when
those kids are in the room they they
they just have it you know what I'm
saying they just whatever it is they
have I told him I said I wish I could
mod your positivity and your energy I'd
be a billionaire they're such good dudes
it's crazy because when when Kade and
and Ty and I first met we just clicked I
mean we just clicked it was like yeah we
just get along so well and I agree I
love their energy I love their Vibe I
love what they represent and obviously
their Jiu-Jitsu is insane taste they put
on and their athleticism and their just
sharpness and submission skills crazy
crazy these guys come to finish and
again you know and that's why we we we
chose you know when we launched the
grappling product just like when we
launched a Muay Thai product um just
like when we launched a kickboxing
product we always start off with trying
to find the most exciting uh best of the
best uh in that specific discipline
because that's what spark that's a spark
that's gonna ignite fandom that allows
us to continue to build that category
right and so we chose Mikey mumii we
chose uh Kaden Tai and I think they're
carrying the flag around the world for
Jiu-Jitsu unbelievable well you know
they're obviously
um really fan friendly but their styles
again are just so exciting and they come
to finish they come to finish yeah and I
think you know the Roo Brothers they're
talking about taking an MMA fight and I
just said why just keep dominating and
he they they both say it's just
something we want to do he was like we'd
love to talk to Chi and figure out one
Championship I'm like have you been
striking and they're like yeah yeah
we've been striking for about two years
now yeah yeah they they they they uh
yeah so since uh and and and the drums
beating louder with Kade kade's like
he's itching ready to go Kade was all
over it kade's the one who was like no
it's going to happen we're talking to
chatry I'm talking to my manager I'm
like damn he's serious yeah yeah yeah t
Tai wants to dominate grappling for a
little bit longer and then potentially
go to MMA yeah but these guys are beast
no matter I mean they're such athletic
specimens and such phenoms that once
they transition to MMA their wrestling
is is on point and their chains are
insane and it's just a matter of time
when they get the Striking up striking
up to up to
speed I don't see any in the world
beating them it's just crazy these guys
have it because if you if you look at
the explosiveness and the cardio they
can go all out for 10 minutes straight
all out you know I mean and that is not
easy the pace they put the combinations
I mean you're a Grappler too Brendon you
know the pace they put is is is it's
crazy I mean when I look at that I'm
like you I've been do I've been doing
jiujitsu for I don't know uh 14 years or
I look at that I'm like man I can do
that 30 seconds of that and then I'm
done they they're freaks they're they're
freaks the pace they put on their
mindset yeah if they want to do it
they're going to do it you know they're
going to be a problem with kind of the
news going on in the Mixed Martial Arts
world and you and I you were actually in
studio when this was going down when
you're negotiating with
Francis looking back on it this my take
on the Francis situation I'd love to get
your thoughts on this you know he
decided to sign with the
pfl but to me it it wouldn't matter if
he signed with any organization whether
it was you pfl somebody else
because of his outcome with Tyson Fury
now is the Joshua fight all you guys
kind of dodged the bullet there meaning
you're not at the kind of the mercy of
Francis and his boxing career because if
you would have signed him it it's mma's
on the back bur I to be honest I don't
think he ever fights MMA again I don't
know why he would with the paydays he's
getting with you know with with Fury and
with Joshua so it kind of worked out for
you guys is that fair to say or no well
I don't I don't really think of it in
those terms Brandon I look at it in
terms of man Francis uh he he nailed it
you know congratulations to Francis I
mean you know the whole world was were
Skeptics and and uh you know he proved
everyone wrong and and so
congratulations to him you know he's
making history and and and um you know I
honestly
thought him fighting Tyson Fury was
crazy I thought me
too beforehand and when the fight
unfolded I'm like oh my gosh he actually
hung in and actually quote unquote beat
I think I thought he won you know I
thought he beat FR I thought I thought
Fran V Tyson um but uh so that I mean
all you can do is applaud and
congratulate Francis there's nothing I
mean I I'm like man hats off to him um
he crafted created his own destiny um
you know he's won in eight billion and
and he's proven it so again like I just
have nothing but but good things to say
about Francis yeah I think with the
whole France thing they're like where's
he going to end up and it doesn't matter
because MMA is a kind of Sidetrack now
no now now and no and the reality is
after the Tyson fight Francis is now
truly uh his own like he's beholden to
nobody when you could fight the very
best in the world the way he did with
Tyson actually beat Tyson
like for lack of a better analog he is
now Mike Tyson like you know you call
the shot correct he call the shot and
he's fighting Joshua now like now he's
fighting Joshua he's making more money
than it's insane so he it really worked
out for him it really worked out for it
was a it was a highrisk high reward
strategy and and and it worked out
beautifully I mean like I said you gota
given his life story of of of working
the minds you know in in Cameroon all
the way to where he is today living on
the streets in Paris homeless like you
you just I mean there's nothing it's
just his his life should be a movie and
it's going to be trust me they I took to
marel is Agent about yeah it sounds like
they're knocking at the door to make a
movie I don't know who's going to play
Francis but I don't see a lot of
Hollywood actors that look like Francis
Ando so good luck with that uh so just
in the MMA landscape pfl obiously made a
splash in the quarter four with their
funding you know the the Saudi funding
uh thoughts on the the pfl growing you
know I I guess it it again it's
different than what you guys do you guys
kind of seeing yourself out
with basically being completely
different than the rest that's how you
guys I I think are why you're growing so
fast you're making all these waves and
obviously pfl's doing their thing um and
they get this funding the Francis news
which really in hindsight's not much
there um you know they acquired Bellator
thoughts on
that so um you know I think everything
comes down to instead of Hyperbole and
hype is look at facts facts and figures
right let's just go to the Facebook page
okay
um and you go to Facebook page for UFC
you go for one I think we're about both
of us are about over 40 million fans gez
look at the engagement rates of fans are
insane on these Pages then you go to pfl
or Bellator and they're at I don't know
1 million two million fans and and very
low engagement rate so you know like um
I I
uh I think there's a lot of Hyperbole
and we will see substance uh down the
road let's you know when the rubber
meets a road let's see what happens um
but for sure um you
know uh I spoke to uh Scott Coker and uh
you know he's just he's he's befuddled
by the whole thing love Scott yeah I
love Scott I think Scott I love Scott
he's a good guy yep and he and I spoke
uh and um he's just befuddled by the
whole thing he's like it doesn't make
any sense what Paramount did but they
did what they did yep I think too when
you talk about meeting the road it's all
about and this what separates you guys
in the UFC it's all about depth when you
when you look at the quality of Fighters
one through 10 you look at matchups that
people are interested in there's UFC
there's one Championship when you look
at the rest there's not a lot of depth
and that that's the issue these
companies have and you know they're
they're also not making Stars that's
that's the other issue well that's a
point that I I was I was stressing is
like you know it it you have to build a
platform first a platform of a Content
engine I.E 61 events a year like we we'
thrown this year but we have our social
media alone has 80 million fans right
you know rot Tang has 5 million fans and
we built organically so meaning that
once and that's the machine of the UFC
that that that they've done so well they
built a Machinery platform that produces
stars um and so has one champion and
these are the only two organizations
where you can generally get when rotin
joined uh one Champion he had like
14,000 followers on Instagram even
though we knew he he had potential
within a few years he has 5 million like
uh on social media like you know this
kind of thing is like you have to it's a
platform business you got to build a
platform you can't just buy one big star
and expect to do well that's works I
mean because you you'll have one great
pay-per-view if you're able to find you
know let's let's take Franc it was
Francis but if you're able to find a
worthy opponent then you could have a
great pay-per-view but it doesn't make a
company agree to to build a league to
build a brand to a UFC and one have to
build a platform it takes years and
years you know we're broadcast live in
190 countries with the largest
broadcasters in Brazil it's Global in
the US it's Amazon in Europe it's sky in
the Middle East it's Bean Sports in
Thailand it's Channel 7 in Japan it's
Aima in Australia it's seven Network
these are the biggest broadcast y b
broadcast in their countries okay um and
and so again it's um I'm not throwing
any hate I'm just um putting a dose of
reality um and again fans can just go to
the social media page go to YouTube page
of of pfl versus versus war or UFC it's
night and day it's night and day so you
need to create you have to have massive
fandom that's you know and so UFC has
massive fandom there's no question about
it okay they have fans who are ra we
have massive fandom that's it these are
the only two comat sports properties
that truly truly have massive fandom
around the world and it's because um you
know we we've we've both built huge
Brands and platforms that's the key
platforms a Content engine of live
sports 61 events every single Friday
here in prime time in Asia once a month
in prime time in the US um that takes a
lot a lot of time and work and and as
you said
Brendon our roster is the best of the
best right yes and we are different it's
it's whether it's MMA mix uh um
kickboxing MTI grappling Etc you know we
sign the very best of the best and
that's why fans want to watch one
Championship nobody wants to watch you
know
um second rate Third Rate fourth rate
Fighters no that's just the reality
agree I agree 100% I I think you nailed
on the head and I knew you guys were on
something good because you know I'm sure
you're aware and you know we don't have
to dwell on it you know there was a
hitpiece about the one uh Championship
financials and I saw and it was right
around the pfl news when it came out and
they're trying to you know shame you
guys I thought oh one Championship is a
threat when I saw that I went oh no
that's this is all crap like that's when
you know when when when you start seeing
stuff like that this kind of you know
it's just hate it's just loser mentality
so when I saw that stuff I was like oh
one Championship must be doing something
right you know the UFC gets it you guys
get it I don't hear anybody else getting
it so there's a there is a hit piece
every year once you know once or twice a
year yep yeah every year uh calling for
a demise that year and what happens
Brandon we hit new record highs every
year yeah for the last seven years so
you know um it's frustrating because
it's it's um it's a it's a false
narrative um and you know it is what it
is but you know how it goes CH I mean
especially at the level you're at like
when that stuffff goes and people want
to see the demise because it's easier to
to you know tear down than to create so
what you've built you know these guys
don't like and they might be loyal to
this organization over here and you guys
are starting to do well so this is
something for them to catch on to cuz
there's not a lot to hate on so that's
one thing to focus on and it pop it
rears its head every year and then it
goes away it's in the media cycle for
about 2 days and then it goes away and
then you guys announce these crazy deals
and the sky Network and you're coming to
America and these two giant Arena you
know fights you're doing so it just it
keeps on moving you know it's expected
it's
expected yeah I mean like I said 2024 is
my team and I are are gearing up for the
best year ever I mean our revenues are
expected to double our on Pace of
doubling uh last year we hit over 100
million in revenues I think it was 110
Million last year around the 110 120
million in revenues uh why I'm saying if
because the final final numbers haven't
come out yet but they will come out in
the next uh you know uh few
weeks um and uh we expect to double our
revenues this year right you know so
again um the the train keeps moving and
it's it's picking up pace momentum
acceleration and and
yeah we're we're we're say to do 61 to
70 events this year alone how many
Global organizations are doing that
level of scale right I mean around the
world with the broadcast 190 countries
live on the biggest broadcasters right
agre again it's it's only UFC and one
and and you guys are expanding mean you
guys are grow to Qatar Japan you know
it's so it's only
expanding you we're super pumped and and
and and that's another thing that that I
uh you know as the home of martial arts
for us you know at one is being able to
showcase the different Arts because you
know every country so in America MMA is
super popular it is the number one
combat sport right um boxing and MMA in
America but if you go country by country
like in China kickboxing is actually
more popular s and Kung Fu they like
striking art is more popular right so
every country again yeah when you have a
when you have a purely American view of
the world you think MMA is the biggest
thing around the no it's not you go to
by country you go to Thailand Muay Thai
is like dominates a million times bigger
than MMA MMA is a DOT no one follows MMA
in Thailand nobody it's like a DOT Muay
Thai is like a religion in Thailand
right so the fact that we're able to do
different martial arts and we're able to
see we're able to mix and match these
fight cards based on geography so when
we come to America we know Americans
absolutely love MMA so we put on Amazing
MMA fights but we also want to showcase
some of the best stri in the world best
graphic so we kind of like introduce you
to a whole another world you know agree
and you I I know Joe Joe loves the you
know the Muay type product that we have
and he talks a lot a lot in his podcast
um and and he was blown away by rotang
right so it's it's it's it's you know
these
guys folks have just never seen Elite
striking at that level forever you know
I mean how many 20 22 year old 23 year
olds have 300 professional fights it's
insane insane when you look at r then
you look at stamp it's just a different
different level yeah Y and then you got
Nikki Holton you know fighting aiyama
which just Mega
fight yeah so that fight we're making
and and it's it's one of those special
mixed rules fights right that we do so
it's three rounds three minutes a piece
the first round is boxing with 4 oun
gloves second round is Muay Tha and you
know in 4 oz gloves and the third is an
MMA round so it's a legendary uh
eight-time kickboxing world champion in
Nikki
holin you know a Japanese MMA Legend So
it's Legend versus Legend in this unique
mixed Rules match that makes people the
you know the Intrigue Factor so that's
the kind of like you know again we're
the home of martial arts so I really
believe
right that martial arts is not a game
meaning that if you're only good at one
rule set then your Martial Arts doesn't
really work martial arts at the end of
the day the essence of martial arts is
can you defend yourself hand toand
combat under any circumstance on the
street corre in the dojo in the ring you
know uh on the battlefield whatever it
is right hand toand combat that's what
martial arts is really about and so the
fact that you know our athletes can
express themselves in different rule
sets and then even in mixed rule sets it
just shows the superiority of their own
um martial arts skills right like how
many um athletes anywhere in the world
comat Sports athletes whether UFC or won
can do What DJ did with Rook Tang like
would you dare to go against a very best
striker in his or her rule set you know
for those three minutes of hell like
it's you have your your Martial Arts
skills have to be at such an elite level
right so that that's why I say DJ is
truly the goat he's like you need to be
able to fight under all circumstances
and Rule sets in order to say are you
really the are you really the greatest
because if you're only good at one rule
set like the unified rule set or good at
boxing rule set you're good at that rule
set you're not necessar the fighter on
the planet you're not not necessarily
the best martial artist on the planet
but if you can fight it under like bro
I'll fight you on the street I'll fight
you in boxing rules I'll fight you in
morti rules I'll fight you in MMA rules
I'll fight you in no rules then damn you
are real you are legit I mean the best
martial artist right d yeah I I dig it
to DJ's credit it's a huge risk man to
try and survive you know for those two
rounds against ratang nut and for aiyama
for sexyama to do against Nikki Holton
those first two rounds going to be tough
man when I saw it I don't like that I
don't like that I wouldn't do
it it's crazy but yeah so I mean you
know that's that the whole kind of like
I guess the whole martial arts
philosophy that we don't we don't see
much in the west uh or don't see at all
right out here in Asia martial arts is
is is really about like that whole
Samurai Bushido Spirit like fighting you
know being able conquer yourself being
able to conquer um uh your fears dots
and insecurities in any circumstance
that the is the essence of martial arts
and and you know that's why millions of
parents across the continent but
actually around the world send their
kids to martial arts schools is to learn
this Warrior spirit this fighting Spirit
of unbreakable spirit being able to
conquer yourself under any circumstance
right and that's something that's old
school Japanese martial arts you know
obviously MMA was was first invented in
Japan 1983 with witho
and um not many American fans know that
they think that UFC is the birth of you
know you know a decade before you know
we had all the different uh had pancreas
like there's a
lot exactly and um and and you know hats
off to the Japanese it's it's the
Japanese culture it's that fighting
culture you know they have I mean even
to this day all the kids train martial
arts all Kendo IO Judo karate since
their kids all of them you know in
school it's it's a way you know American
kids play basketball or or football or
baseball um and uh so that's something I
think that we bring and and that's why
we're doing so well around the world
it's this authenticity it's this sense
of like there's a real depth to uh the
ethos of what we're doing it's not just
trash talking and and who can tweet the
best agree we're looking for the very
best of the best fighters on the planet
who can fight and adapt under any rule
set and this will be my last question
for you but what what's your thoughts on
on kind of the kind of the birth of kind
of the the the YouTuber fighting like
there's a lane and people are watching
you look at the Jake Paul's of the world
the Logan Paul's your thoughts on that
when you when you see what you're doing
then you look at the these kids doing
this kind of you know you got the the
Jake Paul the Nate di stuff um you know
right so so like I I um you know the
world has changed Brendan like before
Sports really was about best of the best
right every and every and now you're
seeing there's the entertainment side of
sport so fans want to watch not
necessarily just the best of the best
now what one Championship does is only
the best of the best so I'm not again
like the the world is big enough where
if if you're a YouTuber and you're a
blue belt Jutsu or blue belt Striker um
and you want to do your thing because
you have a fan base I think that's great
yeah there's a lane for it agree yeah
and it brings more attenion to Combat
Sports in general now if you want to
watch the best of the best on the planet
then you come to one you know then you
watch one right um and I still believe
that you know having the very best of
the best fighters on the planet uh
across disciplines is what at the end of
the day um truly what um is rare and and
magical right I mean I it's like the NBA
World Championships it's like the
English Premier League World
Championships it's like Olympics Olympic
gold medal you know people want to see
the best of the best and then let the
drama unfold organically agree brother
agree 100% well you know I'm I'm I'm
just here from from Calabasas watching
it watching you guys Crush man and you
know I support you guys fully thank you
so much BR you're one of the you know
first guys you know that uh reached out
and just said hey I'm a fan and and this
was a while back so you're one of the
early you know you were one of the early
guys who caught on um and and now
obviously our popularity is is creeping
up and I when I look at the next one two
three years I just think we're going to
explode in the US in popularity because
uh when I look at again our our plans
for the US um big things are coming and
and we're we're we're pumped and I I'll
be there if you have me I'll be there
especially in Denver Atlanta let's do
for sure for sure for sure definitely
man hey thank you so much B I appreciate
it thank you brother enjoy your day man
it's night time here but enjoy your day
over there brother sending love and
positive energy and prayers uh for your
daughter everything works out well
appreciate man thank you so much CH
appreciate you brother bye
bye